я киш номер плану прем'єр-міністр
нічого не юрія душі нол не при сотні за
раз в 11 розділі нерозумності дійдемо на
шоу ряду в Україні розгойдалася озон
зайве на закладення оцінювання з
української мови літератури знайдеш
масового синього не я тут і прийшли
абітурієнти випускники числом фанат
260000 осіп вже в 1100 пунктах тесту
вані та підстилів вкрай
там зла краще але до цілого процесу він
від 43 з половиною тисячі у 4 столітті за
безтурботно it'sa єдиним та процедурам та
проведені для неї і для нас дуже важливі
вишибу але було успішним шиву але було
ганьбою і об'єктивною і ми в 3 малі туди
вірусу спірс твоя каеда за зовнішнього
за хибного тіні що і одним з
таких перших основних коротким для
академічної чесності висвітлю сміття
їдовище
я хотіла показати, з чого ми внесли до
парламенту в законопроекті кого чеку і
мана доступному пленарному у ти ж не
проводив і немає готових 30 мільйонів
ігри війна за забезпечення оплати проти
покращених неприємний kill
а права до низу зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання того, щоб їх нас правді душа
складне процесій на роботу
пов'язана із закриттям процедур по рівер
q і рубає і для нас важливі на шкоду я була
у сприянні та об'єктивно 27 28 травня
вигляд буду тебе свята втомиться дзвін і кіфф
ми будемо омоте
200 з половиною тисячі випускників усі
дити всієї наші випускники та середніх шкіл
та професіонал технічних початкових за
прапори візах у гіпер шудра ремені
акредитації
відриваюсь на годину але документи просто вид
uid уря також зруби у племені заходу та
прийняв постанову щипці вид булат самий
так вручення від таких 28 30
травня від видос для базового світу 8 9
черні
для нас дурова жив його правильно
провести так вже стукну компанію я
cayenne ступні мк роком і цілу мову на
компанія буду а прошу
слайди показуха тут yest that is тыкала
сублімація мабуть важливі ось я заступив
масової інформації то яку я називаю
ванна на слайдах
так і на ступні минулий тут я всі дати
ролики та говорила та
кей писної інформацією доступні пізніше
особливі майстерності та компанії якумо чека
йому ципа першіння як шарф все
абітурієнти подають документи через
інтернет
далі ми даємо йому жив і весь подавати 15
заявка зубна ж кості вийшли до
початкових за охолодимо обмежитися гул
обіймів вищих початкових за охолоджуючи еге
три рази старий джо валите заявок
урізаних спеціальностях в шинах
вони не будуть сконцентровані на тейку
профіт та ченці спеціальностей оковані
реально хочеш а брат її знайти і я до неї
їм природу вигляд косого на пузо
конкурсний у суп ми ви спочатку йому клод
і
із забезпечили йому штук за квотами для
нас дуже важливо так вже система
раз ти стоїть я прибуду розбудив утримана
мовлення
уракова їм пріоритетність у ступників з
високими балами прямо в електроні та
базі і я по ви треба повис тайпан і
прем'єр-міністр пруту про проблему
нас зараз тут з ну і з
проблема з програмним забезпеченням для
їжі на державні електронні бази та
вас квіти державному пік наступності інфо
ресурс у продовжувач кох руки в
програмі забезпечення фактичну 1
рубль алассіо приватну фірму і за раз
бюджеті фігурок уе за клади не кішкою на
викуп всього програмного забезпечення бум
і пари каноне що все програмне
забезпечення державної електронні бази
та й усе так не наших випускників наших
студентів та викладок
вона по виносу проводить якщо ви кришна
на державному ремені
що за скарби не ми на дав і
експертну оцінку і пов'язано
зварювання статті бази і з правову
вузьку тегу договору і для нас дуже
важливо до кінця в степовій та компанії ви
вирішить ці проблеми доступні з
забезпечення доступу до вищого почту
наших дітей українських дітей кізару
живуть наук надії території криму а
так вже над на контрольних території
від зони ато
то вже тут сидить і для нас їжу живо жили
у ммм сьомий рік nier та інтеграції з їх
територій в Україні і ми по ви не зруби
ти в сет для теж були малі доступ до
вийшли з вигляду і в краї не про крим до
готові сесії та до передачі на плитку
тоне не за лижного оцінювання і я до
передачі на тих хто на приклад не
зможеш за 1 клас то його ми перед
бачіли
адже видно змін і до умів прийоми на
основі ухвалених законів про парламент
для таких дітей шубу не могли по трапу
від цього пивних університетів за вступаємо
та випробувані на конкурс на основі алекс
ці університети річки та вокуєва не зони
ато ідея keys знаходиться на території
донбаса adjust народжує тиж вид молоці
кістки абітурієнту
доступна з професіонал технічного
свято дуже важливо проблема я куном
потрібно ви вирішить ці уроку ми ведемо
активну спирт рацію з міністерством
фінансів для вирубано системного
підходу окей води до бюджетного кодексу
2017 раку та та де-не-де в новій редакції
проекту закону про
професій але свиту алла тему так з 2017 я
звикла до тіла reach you reach ми моєму
селом у яка що хлопець атаки кофти та
кієса розірвавши вони разом у бюджетах
дефіцит та 2 мільярди гривою я слухав ми
будемо працювати зараз же
чіткий аналіз за кожним місцем
обласного значення chigon та maite
задухи чого наймається їх доходимо али
інший увійшли vishay момент це буде по чату
до початкового ро кубів першин та травня
замовлення державного і для нас важливі
ваші порвані своїми самоуправліннями
тут ніл та регіональних замовлення а
там dc я prophecy національного значення
ми слабкі в я-то не ви означає з
обсягом того, що ми можемо у дати з
державного бюджету на купу тук нового
початкового уроку там ще це буде
критичний момент
готелю теж функціонувала система
простих у свитої аліни проти
консервації ситуації ми зараз розрубай
його з органом замість його сама в ряду
ваня
регіональний план та модернізацією їх
нікс із центрів та сину технічний та його
свити
доступна мета перед нами будь ласка
доступний слайд е
дуже важливими завданнями in a little
буквально до 1 л сні з свої години до
закінчення підручником і куп не восьмих
класів
там шукаємо ми знаємо і активно суду
проблеми з підручником я його знайду Джова
години з ну адже за раз ми робимо для того
все для того, щоб нас кипить ручних і
будуть година але ми хочемо пари глянути і в
лідку початку програми для пучкові
школи і як я кути його зараза знання
критикою
через те, що перемонтажу називаю
інформації знаю найгірше дітей даному чані
ми хочемо і роботу їм що федотова ти
проект концепції нову українську та
школи за крима він каже і їх на старт
нових конференціях засвіти вона ми
гра мати і все і з країни представляю
нового закону про загальне середнє оточення
який ми вигляд уряду так у нас йому вигляд
pour la
так парламенту я хочу провернути увагу
будь ласка доступний слайд великого на
вигляд будете страшною реформою середнього
квіти у нас сьогодні над звучанням і ми
маргіналізовані професія педагога
професія вчителя та сік роман за війни та
середньому світлі
вбившим і лляним вона наша їжа на
тарифну сітку доповнюйте у нас 4
знаходиться між я ти ледве розпочатим
розряду вона приклад assistent викладок у
вищому початковому заході ж на
позиції 16 розряду на директор
школи гвинт знаходиться не станеш
помічник викладач а так і джиннам і
дині тарифи сіті противний кріс оральні
старі дні з вид з знаходиться повинен
позову і ми по ви не
ви роботи план яким чином мис забезпеч
йому cyprus біля вані і що ми хочемо
реальні реформи за хворі середні у
квіти і наришкін від випадкового жили в
харчуванні координації з органом та місці ви
і влада я прошу повернути якщо на
поверніть бидло ска на 2 слайд і назад
ми його пропустили
такий гетри гарячої води vip це не і я
хочу за розвернутися
з її трибуни до органу вагової влади
алеф нас завтра тупо вигляду я буду також
селектор на нарада дуже процесій але ми
вмовлянням у мережі живлення purchase a
купимо на підручнику для 4 нових класів
сьогодні підлозі ви на дітей на маленьких
підручнику
бо буду там про млинець ну що за
державний бюджет у нього половину
опаловий ну купаєте органи міцели
самоуправління
у них бюджетах єгерем 10 мільйонів
гривень он і по ви не до дати тубі
зараз свою таємницю та закуповувати ці види
учні
шкода нещодавно прийняла постанову на свою
на засіданні д ми дали їм потрібні без
інший тієї пори доплату ви damn it вам у
опція день до 79 сотки в ланцюзі ви на
зняті бар'єри, що потрібно купили у крем
того нам ваше мого акумуля вати все ти
за мовлення тому що ви давність вам ваш
попрати його ти зі шкіряним районам області
державної адміністрації з війни
організовані в цілому ви означає і обсі
чи закупимо непокірний адміністративні
піднімати закупили шкільних автобусів
сьогодні у регіональних бюджетах шукає 100
йони вибухи не знайшли ні та автобуси
он його ця дата свою половину і тут я
хочу про повернуть і увагу
уряду до такої проблеми не всі райони
можемо дозволити собі до дати підлоги
там ще автобус кожні 3 та pidgey не ллє
накривай і статеві на жарт би ти виріс
вміє ще з виворітної суми для диких
районі там у
наша про позиції міністерства святі
наука zara істру вала і внесло на
розвідку 100 нових міністерств із дроту
щоб за їх парі їх можна було пан
язик і накидка що спалахнув не п'яний і
ретельно 50, а чоловікові його на приклад з
перед ніж і не 70 на 30 полонений немає для
я ти какаешь годинник на районі
сьогодні nemo і такий і такого ременя ду
хоне тому що ситуація нас правді я
різьблену і c потрібно ворогові вати та шинні
на випадково важливе харчування формування
maurizio досі немає шкіл ви клану не
ремонтних рубає їх до володіння і так
було виділено на місце very у 200
мільйонів гривень для цього плану не я
наполегливих шкіл що таке наполегливо школа я
хочу за 1 чит код за грубе the definite
ельцова тому що їй дуже багато бідних
трактувати наполегливо школа з школа в
сільські території я саме що і
менше 3 фільм
топ то ще маленькі школи та гі дона і
приємними від філе та та cs школа куди
зірки цедить і для навчання фішок
населених пунктів про обрив дити
старший клас тому що валів нам етап
саяк зруби ти доступ до яскравих нішу та його
почти сільській їх територіях тривають і
дітей старший клас і тому що сьогодні
он і не мої доступу даяки знову свити
пурим на світло не милий одне льотками
наприклад
разом і думаю ми до володіємо самий
сільські школи того часу не куди води
звозять ефектної колишній дітей з ведмедиків
населених пунктів я хочу шпурнути і
увагу collection & nephew ряду сук
романс прибуду харчування ремонту до рихтер
за раз на звучання актуальне харчування при
вертів прем'єр-міністр дати його у вагони
одноразово нам потрібно синхронізувати
за раз пе-2 за не наших дітей
то курс ремонту мер роботами дорогами
там ще нам на кілька треба автобуса нам
по три бен потрібно реально дорога по
такий чоловік і дітей автобус а ножа і в нас
cool та ми пробували масу розпивши розмови
з втратою та місцем його самоуправління з
стрибунова цеху світло його кола ви
значення затятих шкіл всі проблеми так
вже й снують
ми одягаємося до нового уроку в нас
бачить
100 так їх наполегливих шкіл все-таки Петро і
митися доведеться льодом а так вже Петро і
мається стриманого бюджету та місцели
бюджеті алла та органи місцевого самого
думання чоловікові що куш на свої ростуть
значать та й фінансово ти так упор не
школи я боюсь за увагу не готова битва
вісти на все ,
я б мхл нам ми на такий етап це не і
щось слова щодо програмного забезпечення
шутер безробітними куратора ви б
вирішив , сьогодні про бюджет закладу
тест iq мільйонів гривень з закупівлі
лицьового програмного забезпечення
проведено оцінку свого програмного
забезпечення для того, щоб його на
приклад би у нас була також маразлі
даний варіант у площині і киса
альтернативно така програмна
забезпечення аліція знаєш на доріжці та
тим же ти сторони ставка вушка цієї руки
там у нас доведеться його викупу в це для
нас важливі спробувала тимка відвернулась
від міністерства юстиції що було
заплачено правого латинку самого c о
контракту що самим і кукуємо і
інвентаризації та набагато приємного волосся
це вид по видно віку видний тендер
зруб це переговорний процес як наш
краще так щоб ми вступили в стукнув
компанію з читання зрозуміло що у нас я
програмне забезпечення і сильний обсі
дні заходу дробними зручно то в результаті
проводити все придумав закону процедури
і в саша подає ногу до запуску система
запуску чомусь ручним або устам тепер
на заміну светра протитечії живлення
спирті міністра всіх порушить
ти часом засвоїться того, хто летить. нам термо
ви означає і територіями
recurl з забезпечені догляду мені
адушкіна виховую деталь
випробування моя but i
пріоритет у полі зоран знижки
так штовхаю ще я особисто ти готова на в
Дашкін і вона підкреслила школа вже
яка при праведному багажі знань cd
я можна їсти деталь ніби пишу нудну
школі ось уже важливі ваші б ми і на
ремені дашкін хіба ти відразу мило
ситуацію в Україні
у нас їй інструменти цього фонду
оригінального розведення я думаю що це
харчування
пріоритети для листової влади у гості
обкладатися трояндами та
аличі ми з вами знаємо що силі
стає харчування нам дати можна весь
вчить якими ти я зможу там роботах про
плані давно їжі для нас і в цих
регіонах
критичний стан забезпечення місцями до
летять садочку і ми будемо допомагати
урумова до фінансової децентралізації та
чоловіки разом адже когось navi руку я
наговори буду вотана медичні хочу на
Її добу можна буде налаштувати опцію
придуманої побуду вам наяди алое роботи
нами групи
нові місця зафарбовують розуму ви пробували
дітей з донькою зовсім наших потреб то
ми явно проти щоб знати цілу владу
випробування оплаті вали і ми розуміємо life
is an реальні станція начинки
статистичної та фактично доступно та
харчування та кепку тобі ще більше межі
папір
таки на всіх українських рівним я
адже можна там десь мати право це
набір давайте об'єктивно цьому нам треба
що збила ти чоловік новини роботи літніх
фришкін і хд урвище
куртку і типу тому не танув і не спраги
та й по видний
місці куди по трапі то там біля тошиби
тут у мотатися харчування з місцями
областями і розширить і можна ввести до 2
2 за збитих тільки з дітей і може
витратити кілька тисяч фнатики ль
козмін на такі стрибки адже мені починати
там ще баки процедури не всі грі кішки
вивести на на зборищі чорному морі сам не
катували а де ти просто захопленні биту акцію
організований промокашка ніхто барів я
просив Сем це ж просто межі тієї про
попка ти пам'ятаєш вузлам із води по три
бойові розв'язання проблеми і ще добріший ще
ви говорили про регіональними дружинами
за новими та за розміном
стані підготовки кадрів давайте
давно буде тобі спадкоємство без адже
видно підготовлених викравши побуту і вам
шкірянці рен і спадкоємство скажи ще провину 3
травня молодих
люди ці надходить на роботу
непідготовленим ви не знаєте учасник
готової він і не знаєте після сучасної та
плавання в бійську у своїй та виключення
алея вулиця раз про правила е це докази
дають і рівну там чи не світлоярську
розумі
all і більше зі своїми встатку вони я
змусила технології за стріли, а ми
виключаємо у десятки мільярдів на
підготовку дітей мало того, що ми
повертаємо шкіри ти хилиш і їдемо на
конкурентами і в 3-го по темному рівні
якщо рукавичок цьому він на місяці програма
ночами він на хвилі основних фондів
харчування ось просто архіважливо його душі
провідник то вони б то не я порушила я
хотіла колишній дозволить вони дорого і
поправи істина технічніше освітлення
для нас важливий його все-таки краще ти
бізнес до того щоб він випив він
фінансово спрямуй істину технічного
кольору та мислити but i'm at його тінистий
мун і ми вже теж у цю
консультувалася з міністерством
фінансів чим можемо, а ми розвинули ну так
що я таким вже жвавості річки проціди їж
їх краї нах а що ван і вкладиш
підготовку викравши ту суму виплат q-tip
та дотки
вид носяться на валові витрати та тупицею
реальним від його тини інструмент для
бізнесу вкладу цих гаїв сьогодні такого
інструмента на ну і там його на
дистанції його не янкул і робик
паралельну систему вид вище не
кваліфікації своїх кадри там чи що
можна цируля ну тайці bloody знову голим
холодним джерел він фінансово не я просто
до квіти та астани продажів кивнула кольору у
нас я хочу за інформацією
а крем tedx засоби вікі що і на
називати прем'єр-міністр, а сам це ще
органи місць ліву самоуправління на жаль
рушили ось і моріучі розвинений але в лініях
root на три баги татушки рюкзак лаги
перевищення цих займає зовсім і не
чужі інституті та виглядом чиїмись ряду не
дужки поза плодами червоними моєму дати
чоловіки без розвитку приховувати не
ініціативи і ми за раз підтвердили
на шкоду та здоров'я та мінюстом новий
санпін та на дошкільному заході вікі
дозволить відкривати і маленький стрибати
не з точки вона нам так уже потреба
забезпечить ідуть від hkuwist примули по в я
занесу орендну плату з носінням оренди
для них щоб він з і ти варіння з
перебування цик дітей у таких приватних
з точками та зруби це та їх без
доступними для населення в Україні
я документально я думаю звучать і бізнес
у простих свитках з правильно я
говорю про таїсію моєму сьогодні
піддавайтеся на ефективність ми просто
немає державних у тисняві та програмою
підготовки цикади
там на хліб до вечірні резерви я на
приклад можна сказати ще сьогодні
уявляєте ці сфери він її сьогодні
іншу з вузом його не gratuït допомагали
на тренд якщо база на вулиці ranger а ще
фасується тому багате
промислових та принципі китаю шприцу і до
допомагаєте senja
нам потрібно повним провести
модернізацію і ось те, що ви сказали я
думаю все наступної години три десятки
кіпру позиції і дозволено ми відразу мід і
пара ми почали яблук на vento
саме це і в центрі мого стільця то ви
по світу треба або виступати з найголовніше
найвище інвестиції розуміємо роботи в
яскравих тус вигляд і не в диплом від я дещо
почти в prophecy не новачки
цінами від її але роботи я пам'ятаю сім'ї
соратникам та супротивникам українського
світло та підручником голови адміністрації
я думаю що почути висилати те
проводіть броні божий щоб навичка
вона в завданні з пробаню
підручнику виділяють для дітей перед та
самі доповіді ти до школи предмети та все
таки є як запас підземних
звіти в стеку сечею йому проти стріли
накупила не віддалася відчуття
травня but i Петро учні закуплені роше не
проблемний травень цього підлітка
хотів би щоб усі почули міністрів
святі з точки зони закупили підручнику
для нормального спить і дітей
пушкіним автобусом теж сама позиція
думаю вистригти і сьогодні в рамках
фінансової децентралізації ще не на
ремені району
tonari за межами області ресурси активний
може просто робите придбати все
автобуси 600 мільйонів мами циклами
знайдуть на мою і що мені пам'ять не за
джиммі утримували в 24 мільярди сьогодні
діти за ложки цьому там я ресурси і що
потрібно давайте візьмемо тепер названий
або лямками шкірок шкірну область сядемо
по воротах це дається і кішки може
будуть для надання і по дорогах та
ж сама позиція просіть доступні
до нової адміністрації з ЖКГ
схожим знудило формі давайте спрацювати
паспорт проблемних це не просто школа
та й здорово тобто
автобус датчики випробування це допоможемо
іссаві володарі що ці завдання я
готовий cyan
le mans там область в тюрму дякую
і хочу потиснути руку спікер я про посилання
щоб дала мені в рот не одразу поле не
буде ремонтом доступності дітей до
точки не захопивши і буду з нетерпінням
чика ти про позиції щось змінити
системі
яскраві сни змінені у складі проксі на
технічне світло і давно стало і в нас
копитами легендарно чикаго струму і робити
далі насторожі
але сторожі хоча б те, що ми вже
перекинули на рівні містер і сама
видування 6 суецьким харчування
то тут всі тебе позиції мої ідоли та
давай позицію купили моєму поливати за
не знав місцями самоуправління так і не
грішив і й до сьогодні по
здорово не так
розрулювати програми ovation може
забуті місця райони всі зароблені
може і машинах і закладатися
відбитки та у шов звільнити по
підручні як місця може зуби ти мені
схему чекаю у себе бюджету
чорний може бути або їх владних
доході впадає там 22 з половиною
сотки у але все розписано хотілося щоб
всю позицію якусі розписалася штука на
шляху мені стало побудувати проблемою виріс
на місці фінансовим скажеш собі
подальше чиновник він чи моя позиція
таку
і логічно наша дискусія до того ж бувало
зараз бюджетному процесу морально
середнього свято небо з куща в мою голку
ризикову і в анапу ви на це і розум
субвенції державному бюджету через
спинку так само кіпр офісі на
технічного свята каеф конституції поверх
су проводиться з google team загартовані та
середній там його я по сайту що мої гути
субвенція ви не ставите бюджет та
алли в процесі децентралізації ми
реально передав їх нічників ти на мене
проблема поля гоїв
вже про неї в таборі знаєте в кілька стець їх
доходимо в різьблених у різьблених органах місця
його самоуправління
цьому ми за 1 процедуру з міністерством
фінансів для того, щоб з балансу вати
ситуацію були якісь реально може
все-таки зрубує і прийти з правої річки
кому дровам вид видно дапоміг ти
натиснув міністерство усвяти та наукою
сьогодні ноймайер those that них
фінансовим важливим для того, щоб саму
сильно примати давання рішення і до
фінансово ти
ціль тут не міністерство фінансів і ми
на мага і ми усвідомлюємо випивши проти ти
можете десь до тієї дірки в рамках
фінансової децентралізації реальних
ресурсів на місце стало біржі в рази
більше про дику центральну модель всім
ситуація стала на хеші малі для такої
добру скільки ван еген і сама дістати
не за допомогою цього харчування сама
доступності добрий видного об'єктами
я коспрі ось цю тому чорні балики
громади
об'єктну частину в одну your особисту
структуру сама будь не стала завищується
називає кордони всі слухаються дати
чоловіки без тут роботи таки з бюджету
такі фінансові інструменти від місця
обласного значення цьому тут треба
не тільки продавати і кішки і 42 тобі
твій дальність аліса михайлівна
щоб system on us with і яскравим сиськом
мажете
холодно здоров'я на брехло буду я
кислими більш cша система наяки сну ми
можемо дати в два рази менше, ніж у
три рази біржі теж хороший а на яхті з
підготовки до дверей в ні щось означає
там і в даному випадку можна купити і
міністра святі та наукою теж правильний
і комбінування мови пов'язане з
святу і фінансово не його почту ти
правильно плюс а досі не школи все
правильно оскільки ми зможемо дізнатися що
змінити колеса світло і змістимо ось і
ряд харчування acer тасує взятий на шлюб
ладушки для цитата
місцями хору не вlogged так вони вигляд
поїдає кому в дорозі точок і c
правильно я думаю тут їй повний баланс
взаємодій між центральним органом
володіємо з семом ми можемо продавати та
фінанси і ви намагалися за я кісту свитою
піду але ви майже їх що ми готуємо
повернув відсікав кадр і зовсім не технічний
кадри рахунок я означає все означає
у шкірні області є своя владна
структура групи стогін та пріоритет
ніколозі розведення економіки іван цю
дірку турити кадр зірка їй
міжрегіональне бюро загальна
національні харчування празі сказала
ліберальної тут міністерство як цим
чоловікам незабаром у цю систему і
підготовки замок на неї відчиняються
кадри заводжу його olight треба щоб шкіра
не орган влади стукався у політику
академічної рожеві така кіста свити
стрибки ріжте яскраві жити а я кисло
роботою окисленого свято цілитися яки
жити я буду цьому ми тут моїм тільки
буду вати з міс ямано води партнерські
сосунки примудрився чого я до всіх цокати
квітам суду здебільшого налили махами
я не відкривав цю це мати ще у
структури tedx структури про середовище
складу простих у святих завели
вона була трохи так на периферії
збоку міністерство по світу гнуться
проти мусик 25 разів я чому віддадуть
у мощей стукнувшись проблема в чому
каліцтві разом вінниці
9 професіонал технічних вчився був і
порядок
з вами без свого бюджету я скажу ще
там також братові проблем яскраві
матеріально-технічні бази
скільки інвентаризації немайн вони землі
не проводилося дуже багато там біля рота
жителі vaquero нижчого кристали для
студентів обидва прохолодний піджить лох
above за галиба хрестові ціни за при
значенням за гіркотою піддавайтеся на
структуру замок та tedx ліцензованих
спеціальностей акіматів річки
фахівця яких випускає то шкір
них рабів скажемо з села kenzie в
закладі відмінно дей автономно без
всякого складового плану я так розумію за
розбудить вже серйозні зміни у чомусь вигляд
ніж та як води ось тут на 1000 пасаж
таким і ви вирішила проблему передачі cx
закладок сама ікша можу ринку вигляд по
вітальність направо це чим керувати
цим і закон про цю регіональну
новими місцями анапана потрібно мене ти
форму владності цик зате таборі
порадіти їх я kno мішки ерівань
обласного значення такі спину владний
spirit реальний храм від областей для
подачі залишайтеся коли всі я хочу
петром і т.д. проти його професій на
технічного свята спраги за знову ланіту
фінансово не недоліки і біля води
цитати ви на цьому прийшла таке вас
там їхня купа ламай йому і кинься купою за
плоди також порада профі сенат їх нічні
квіти ванни а просто назву чай новизна
рахую передачі на ваги гривою я вважаю
що передача травня bootes дій на
розум сповн повагою і all підсумки коли
типів navajo не будуть доміно влади ви
еривань коли сьогодні води перед вони
маленьким не сам обласного значення
Які приварені встань і фінансово ти
професіонал технічний заклад
to take all передача може навести лише
та до 1 до ліквідації цех професіонал
технічних закладів без аналізу по
трибуні його початкова по три мені
просто щоб car is the new з них
стрибнеш день приватизації їх про
мішеней засипе їм сицилії нашим метаном
це до наших ця модернізація
світи приведення до потреб регіональних
ринку у профі
це ми передачу тут на мій iq тільки
ви знаєте
ми з вигляду видно і закону на кому
ревниво не може but i
наношу думку c обласний ревінь гривень
mist
обласних центрів а так вже місця
обласного значення якима its почнуть
сусідній з нас ціла ouji нормально the
kidneys владних бюджеті та он і може
собі дасть ось це відомий вата
регіонально замовлення
prophecy начитка витають міністру
правильно душі після давно ви означало
nike ремені можна продавати таких лопатка
і риба труби ти за стрижень у жадібних
катувати приватизації мені може but if зао
особи моїх but i умова передачі я чорний
дай бог перепрофілювання я все на цій
бога нам обмежуся продати відразу моєму
ти цех повернуть держава влада як за
рухливий він нам потрібна тісна
професій на технічному свято я дещо
не харчування я б за краєм балона чи
че почем олександр
данілюк річку я хотіла захід цього лемеша
нею атмана загнали ставиться до
перспектив в офісі на технічне свято
практично у всіх успішних європейських
коін дтк свитої основі е модель
дуального свити у нас на сьогодні я профі
сильно технічна світлова фактично
засунеш янська після агентської моделі я
обожнюю ще надходив випадково збив їх мою
статеву до ваших зусиль висоти і ось і
вашу систему ми можемо бути якщо простий
логіки ось йому ось цю систему і напуває і
даного і логіки інакше ми повинні будемо
повертатися в ті ситуації і кутик ще
Володимир Борисович процедура
підлога у нас на редон хто кого і зійти на
спеціальності мега туре та плюс я ще ми
вийдемо владу зі зв'язків ської логіки ми
зможемо реалізувати вашу ідею ще до
реального за лучини бізнесу
а ще ми повертатимемося і приховуємо від
та офісі на технічного свята сьогодні вона
реально , ​​нікуди і вимиєте багата туші
тикових я обожнюю креативних ідей для
середнього світла та києвом обожнюю викрасти
це алея то пішло частіше в Америку вали
проти вийти із логіки його вимоги
паска зухвалу систему в аффективно
технічні свята і не просто займалася
фінансуванням я не опинитися за
харчування та накладання про дуальна
система свята хочу я псих сказати про
рахунку аль нас система вас вигляд і поливаючи
кутники соціального вигляду падальності
бізнесу і до і нас твоєму майдан чеку
дозволяючи проводять та навчання друк від
початкового процесу підготовкою до
професії практично напіввину початковому
години і наприклад такі традиції у не
менше не аламуті самі не менше не
хочеш провернути
увагу що вся професій на асв теж
професіонал технічного свята
забувається дітьми віконда 18 року
фінансується із федерального бюджету
бюджету федерального ревеню там шукають sam
va негайно стіняться
про святі ікони upside на люди не щоб
вона могла реалізувати з тобою в жеку
їй лише adjust і направ і сильні про
світи курчат їх людей яким же виконала
save 17 рокки я пизду буває вже не
парять сальну середню святу до данської
якусі професію там
фінансово не ж і наші там і нам треба
так у їстівного ти щось складу
питання сильного святі яко забувається
поруч з
завалені середню святу не минулі
мая петер і молодість і державою я
курю унікально разом у короткий
коментар ми зведемо і навіть
конструктивно вихователем із міністром
java +
вашої особи статусу цінам в 7 плюс там
ще й обожнюю але вторинні калугу
підійди було прийнято потім вона
здалася дуже добрий і продуманий
історія ті проблеми так цьому зарості
конструктивом просив його з знаходимо ви
ви кит всієї ситуації і тут ми підходимо
комплексно на всіх повній розуміння і я
хочу по трьох це ж казав потрапив
анатолійович це вимагає ці 7 будні і я
люблять правильне рішення це як
prophecy над їхнім особистим почетом буде
фінансуватися
тут моя проти розуму 4g рава затриманих
джед обласний бюджет бюджету місяць а
також бізнес і виходимо з 3 коментарів
пишеться столітті у нас за в'язання натиснувши
так друга з мотивація в принципі ну
ті хто відривати додати її матір
фінансово ти і 3 с з промахнися до
фінансування ось ми комплексно ціль і
виймайся за раз прописаному часто
закон prophecy на технічне світло і
cbd problem аналітики на сьогодні вона
палата років але мій шлях не оптимус
прайм та рекламна кампанія дякую вам за
презентацію в центрі києва розставила
хочу ще раз усіх за полювання ти до
допомагати розвивати у нас нами на святу
тим більше тим більше, що у нас є
сьогодні було чесно конкуренція ви знаєте
ще на зимові узи
сьогодні про допоможе нашим дітям ніч вони
вже тут і with beer в Україні проводять і
зустріч шо у нас є щеціні she
ніш наш інтелектуальний потенціал та наш
edit нічим не до того тут важливі в дієту та
ту ж душу та посилай секція трояндами ти
це допомагати кипить робота міністерства
світло я великий аллах marble blast
холоду
водну росію на реакція за раз кров і
дуже технічний заклад епохи
вже об'їжджаючи територію України та за
минулий
у вована безкоштовно і мовчання наших
дітей - відеокамеру я cases with і без
позування прив'язана до здоров'я дітей
і я пропишу джипа будинків сільській школі я
дуже прошу що новий ряд ви просто тупо
милку жартував про мірабелла
а сама 30900 дітей закидаюсь школу та
скручених арабам упустив травлення і
ножа пов'язок інший те щоб
школу за кекс у нас здорово нація та
здоров'я де ти цьому перетвориться на
дайку не зламаний є рівень вмістив
усама радості я минулого і відразу менше
5-ти до законопроекту
активностями до Верховної Ради цей лист
і після ти мені рекомендації що до
обов'язково в цій не облаву сковував
харчування всіх дітей та всіх класів
візерунки у світ не школах завитку видно по
платну за руку міг бути краще про рану
місця в сомбреро не компенсацію алла
потрібні владі мальте а літр обох за
блага за ти там у що
катетер fashion про ситуацію та здоров'я
дітей може розвинути цю те, що не
знаєш але вилейки біганини кошти і будемо
далі movie стирчать та
на тріумфування ті ж самі дітей дияконом
абсолютно розумний підхід
тим більше ще такі комбіновані
системи оплати
може бути абсолютно нормально зістрибніть
минулого лінкольна відсотки при давайте
Петро mc про мову і я думаю що і
абсолютно нормально можна оцінити риба
проколоті закони можна центром можна
його і прийняті зайвому ряду давайте
розглянемо мерехтять можна вильотом
прийнятим і виявлятися у гіршому
діапазоні 100
дякую